voilà je voulais que c'eut été avec nous
en plateau c'est un peu modifié ce que
vous dites à la fin du sujet faut pas
boire veut pas manger faut pas s'asseoir
quand on est une princesse mais même pas
quand on est une artiste on est à nous
en serons saute quand on est habillé en
soit on ne boit pas ne soit pas d'accord
parce que on peut abîmer son costume
voilà les chaussons et puis au moulin
rouge
on n'a pas le temps de s'asseoir on va
parler de votre expérience au moulin où
j'ai rejoint le banc ce soir jeudi mais
d'abord je vais revenir sur cet atelier
que vous avez menées à amani magny les
hameaux
comment on apprend vous êtes arrivé
voilà ce type d'atelier je travaille à
une fois que j'ai quitté le moulin rouge
et travaillé au musée en herbe
j'ai travaillé au moins je pars une
vingtaine d'années musée en herbe et
j'ai créé les premiers ateliers de
costumes
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des
thématiques dans les expositions et à la
fin de la visite d'une exposition les
enfants avec des ateliers différents et
moi j'ai commencé à faire les ateliers
de costumes qui ont été vraiment un bon
succès et on avait une aire pour faire
effectivement un costume avec 30 enfants
une heure c'est rapide très rapide c'est
d'ailleurs avec lui dans la machine
s'est on a vu que des petites princesses
et oui mais ça veut dire que les pour
les petits princes n'était pas exclue
quand même en italie mais il faisait les
châteaux ah voila voila le prince fait
le château oui voilà pour défendre tout
en carton dans carton et oui le prince
et guerrier fait son château fort
également la princesse fait sa robe pour
trouver son prince charmant
tout cela est fort logique gsm que ce
qu'est ce qui vous a transmis la passion
de la couture tout s'est tu quand
j'étais petit
tout seul oui personne nous a toujours
interdit de coudre commencez vous à moi
ça je partage chez les voisines
le côté merveilleux ce cas la campagne
les portes s'ouvrent peut-être que dans
l'est dans les villes aussi mais on peut
faire tout et les voisines dans la
matinée expliquez moi excusez moi je
reviens pas dessus pourquoi vous
empêcher de passer mes parents voulaient
pas que je cours c'est vrai mais oui
mais oui c'est pour eux c'était pas
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
ça va être au service et des autres
voilà ok c'était ma valorisant oui parce
qu'il voyait que la couturière du
quartier il ne voyait pas du tout que
moi je resterai pas à la campagne et moi
j'étais toujours j'ai fait part ici
originaire de quelle région des pyrénées
et je tricote aurait déplu monsieur si
çà mau mais tu verras un jour je tricote
trait de plume
elle avait votre parcours est pas mal a
dû être fier je les tue pendant des
années je disais pas que je te voyais
moulin s'élevant à ce que ma famille
voulait pas il pensait que c'était un
mauvais lieu alors qu'il n'y avait pas
plus confortable et morale
le moulin rouge elle vise à nous le
raconter tout ça dans notre camp on est
très contentes avec juillet est très
fière de vous recevoir parce que quand
je dis m'a parlé effectivement vous
étiez habilleuse au moulin rouge nos
yeux ce sont les merveilleux en disant
mais quelle anecdote il doit y avoir à
raconter
oui donc vous êtes vous y être entré en
1977 voilà en tant qu habilleuse avant
de partager tous vos souvenirs et vos
anecdotes on va regarder ce que pensent
les saint quentinois du moulin rouge au
cabaret qu'apparaît dîner-spectacle
paris spectacle qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire d'autre
femmes la danse à paris ce cabaret avec
le french cancan moulin rouge au film ça
me fait penser au cabaret à paris le
paris
le
c'est un spectacle une salle de
spectacle paris cabaret moulin rouge à
paris à celle a commencé là c'est le
french cancan
alors seulement une personne n'a évoqué
le french cancan et aucun la
magnificience des costumes que vous avez
pourtant eu entre les mains pendant
presque dix ans et en quoi consiste
exactement votre métier d' habilleuse
alors le métier dhabi yeux était
d'accompagner les la troupe les danseurs
où les danseuses dans les changements de
costumes et la préparation aussi avant
de rentrer en scène c'est à dire qu'il
ya un plusieurs clou il ya un mur farci
de cloud il ya des noms ou des numéros
les prénoms des danseuses et les numéros
en fonctions viennent plusieurs fois on
va pas remettre plusieurs fois le prénom
et puis ça change tout le temps de
couleurs donc on sait exactement que le
numéro de temps correspond à t-elle de
tableau et que le prénom correspond à
tel tableau
voilà où il c'est une histoire de cloud
en fait ça c'est pour la partie
rangement s'est rangé une réparation de
la station réparation feu que quand la
fille arrive elle est toute mignonne
vous imaginez une jeune fille bien
maquillée ravissante qui a déjà la plume
sur la tête
les bijoux etc à une petite poubelle à
la main parce que dans la poubelle ya
les changements il ya des boucliers les
souliers
il ya le prochain changement dont on
voit ces jolies jeunes filles qui se
promène dans les couloirs avec toute la
une petite poubelle de différentes
couleurs en fonction des loges et vous
avez trois minutes maximum c'est ça fait
mal changé tout changer tout changer
dans kaléya et quand il ya les gants
c'est encore pire
il ya les bijoux des les bracelets il ya
des boucles d'oreilles hayatou le
soutien gorge le string
tout est à changer et justement quelles
particularités on ses vêtements ils
n'ont pas de
bouton j'imagine ils ont des gros
crochet un petit peu de velcro mais
surtout des grands crochets qui
s'approche en une seule fois que de
fermetures éclair j'imagine le camp
juste là les grandes robes oui c'est pas
d'accord et alors vous êtes une équipe
de 20 personnes se sentent une tente
même ça va très vite
il ya deux revues par jour quelle est
l'ambiance dans les coulisses bel
endroit j'ai dit que ça doit pas rigoler
on n'a pas le temps de plaisir c'est pas
pour vous le plaisir c'est pour les gens
qui ont payé et qui sont devant nous on
travaille on est dans la concentration
parce que tout tout est géré par la
musique elle ne s'arrêtera pas on peut
pas faire rater une sortie de plateau a
une fille d'une entrée rien donc ces
huiles et on peut dire sur ses villes et
ses militaires d'où le terme de revues
de revue il ya eu deux capitaines des
guerres il ya une capitaine des boys
voilà
et vraiment ça marche très bien parce
que chacun est à sa place on te parle on
est très concentrés et que l'iliade une
mauvaise humeur il faut pas que millions
les relèves
et comme bien gérés izard comment vous
gérez les inoublis elle n'est pas là
pour ça elle ne les lieux quelles
qualités il faut pour être une bonne
habilleuse dans les coulisses du mois
qu'il faut avoir une observation rapide
sentir quand justement la fille peut
être elle aussi parce qu'elle n'était
pas bien en scène n'allait pas bien en
coulisses
donc il faut effectivement neutraliser
très très vite une tension qui arrive
tout de suite devenir ma chérie pause je
suis là je suis là depuis la mer que les
petits mots dans le match il ya des
petits mots fonctionnement 12 ans a
effectué un pas mais lui s'est affaissé
lacalm un sac à main qu'elle allait lui
prélever a l'impression qu'elle est
reprise en main voilà
et aujourd'hui vous garder quand même
des beaux souvenirs et des amitiés ou
via nos amitiés oui il garder amitié
avec six ans les artisans parce que les
artisans jeu des rencontres encore et on
se fait des petites fait de temps en
temps et on a beaucoup de plaisir à se
retrouver
c'est un très très bon esprit de
travail c'est une famille c'est d'une
famille était très familial on pense
malgré la grande maison
il ya une attention justement même à la
femme n'y a pas beaucoup de femmes qui
ont des enfants
eh ben il ya une jeune femme qui vient
d'avoir un bébé elle habite pas très
loin du moulin
mais elle s'en va pour les donner la
tétée à son bébé elle revient troyer cas
beaucoup de maisons qui font ça mais il
n'y a pas beaucoup de bébés ou la moye a
pas d'histoire d'amour n'ont pas trop
aux médias parce que ça passe trop vite
elle reste pas suffisamment de temps à
paris elles vont ensuite une verdoodt
comptera donc effectivement il se passe
pas grand chose mais beaucoup d'amitié
oui il ya une très belle ambiance d'un
peu comme des frères et soeurs il a
serré sous lui oui oui ces colonies une
vacance qu'au moulin rouge et vous y
retournez jeu
au moulin oui pour voir des revues ou
dans les coulisses dans les classes
également parce que j'aime bien aller
revoir et puis j'ai organisé des
expositions autour du moulin rouge donc
sur l'occasion de me retremper voilà
donc j'étais sans doute aussi des petits
stagiaires que j'accompagne pour des
petits stages et voilà ça nous permet de
revenir vous décrochez jamais trop
annonceurs actuellement qu'on décourage
pas du moulin rouge en institution qui
marque j -marc qui marque et qui m'ont
appris que le plaisir ça se gérer ça se
gérer qu'il y avait une sagesse avoir à
gérer le plaisir des hommes d'accord
merci
vous parlez aussi joliment du moulin
rouge et vous avez un très joli port de
corps comme comme les danseuses du monde
merci également aux va continuer on va
continuer se fit dans quelques instants
il sera question de femmes chefs
d'entreprise mais d'abord une plongée
dans un monde d'hommes celui du gel
le groupement d'exploration de longue
durée si on regarde incendie dans un
tunnel du fort de saint cyr à montigny
le bretonneux
la fumée était épaisse l'unité en
formation du groupe d'exploration donc
durer avant salle aveugle
l'objectif de cette simulation récupérer
deux mannequins un adulte de 70 kg et un
enfant le gel des spécialisée dans les
opérations de secours dans les tunnels
les caves où les parkings envahi de
fumée ou de gaz toxiques
l'objectif de la d'exercice et mettre la
victime dans une couverture d'extraction
pour faciliter son dégagement
d'accord c'est pour ça qu'on sort pas
tout de suite on la met en place là pour
gagner un peu de temps et après pouvoir
la sortir rapidement
ils sont en opération depuis deux heures
avec 25 kg de matériel sur le dos alors
pour tester leur lucidité les candidats
remplissent un questionnaire avant
l'extraction
les maîtrisent tous l'escaladent ou la
plongée ou au moins 5 à 10 ans
d'expérience de sapeurs pompiers au
départ de la formation il ya un an ils
étaient 27
il ne reste plus que cinq landes en
phase d'apprentissage donc là c'était
plus apprendre à utiliser du nouveau
matériel
après on a travaillé avec bilan de
l'exercice de victimes sauver mais
surtout des situations dangereuses
appréhendé en équipe
depuis l' incendie dans le tunnel de
l'a86 en 2002 la sécurité en milieu
souterrain est une priorité dans le
département avec la future ligne 6 du
tramway à vélizy le domaine
d'intervention du gel seront élargies
dans quelques mois